you just imagine may notice I've changed
the title of my talk so initially I was
planning on giving kind of a normal
research talk focusing on some specific
problems but then when I sat down to
write the talk I thought what the heck
I'm going to try to organize this around
what I think is a sort of fundamental
problem in this area and all of the
other problems that we see are sort of
would be much easier to solve if we
could address this fundamental problem I
don't get a chance to talk to you all
that often so might as well give it a
try so this is joint work with a
graduate student at Princeton named
Dennis fee him and a lot of this work
will be part of his dissertation so that
if there are any ideas in this talk that
you like they probably came from Dennis
and then I'm also going to talk some
about a specific empirical project we
did in Rwanda and these are the
collaborators on the project in Rwanda
so for about 10 years now I've been
working on problems sort of at the
intersection of networks and statistics
motivated by this empirical problem that
is there about 30 to 35 million people
in the world who have HIV and in most
countries this disease is concentrated
among the people most at risk for the
disease are in these three risk groups
drug injectors sex workers and men who
have sex with men and so we'd like to
know more about these groups so that we
can understand how the disease spreads
and so that we can effectively design
interventions so sort of catchphrase for
this and public health is no your
epidemic so now to make this a little
more concrete imagine if you're the
director of UN aids the UN hiv/aids
organization and your goal is to stop
the spread of HIV in the world it would
be very difficult if you didn't have
reliable information about the group's
most at risk for the disease and that's
kind of the situation that we're in now
it's sort of like you're flying blind
because it's so difficult to collect
this information and the reason is that
these groups are very hard to study
using standard sampling methods so the
kinds of questions that we ask about
these groups they're actually really
easy to state so typical questions are
like this what percentage of drug
injectors
San Francisco have HIV a second question
that comes up frequently is how many
drug injectors are there in San
Francisco so these are questions about
the prevalence of some trait within the
heart to reach group and then the size
of the hard to reach group and so I've
worked on methods like respondent driven
sampling and the network scallop method
which are both network based methods for
trying to answer questions like these
one aspect of these I think is different
than a lot of the other things will hear
about today a lot of in these settings
were most interested in characteristics
of the nodes and the edges are just ways
of accessing those nodes so a lot of the
talks we've heard so far I've been
interested in network structure itself
these were really just interested in the
nodes the network structure is just a
vehicle to access them however it turns
out that properties of the network
structure affect our abilities to answer
these questions so as I said I've been
working on this for a while and i think
the sort of it's often not completely
satisfying because of this problem is
how can we actually improve if we don't
know how we're doing so this is a little
bit metaphysical i've tried to keep it
intentionally vague for a second because
i imagine that many of you have
addressed problems like this in your own
field and so i'm very curious to hear
how people try to solve this problem in
terms of the area where i work in with
these hidden populations I will sort of
character I will sort of turn myself
into a straw man for a second to give a
concrete example of this so this is from
a study that I did with a number of
Brazilian epidemiologist to estimate the
number of heavy drug users in curitiba
brazil it's a city of about two million
people in southern Brazil so here the x
axis is the estimated proportion of the
population that youth is a heavy drug
user and these are five different
estimation methods for now we can just
forget about these what these mean so
basically we produce five different
estimates that differ by a factor of 10
so then the natural question that the
people in Brazil ask is okay great which
of these is right
and the honest answer is we don't know
all we know is that they are different a
one side note we heard some stuff about
data availability earlier I want to say
that in all of our work we try really
hard to make the data publicly available
given the legal and ethical constraints
so and this for example for this
particular paper all the data is
publicly available in the office of
population research data archive ok so
now I'm going to try to tighten up my
question a little bit make it a little
bit less metaphysical so how can we
reliably make progress in our ability to
estimate quantities that will never be
known and but I never be known I don't
mean that we can't define these things
so we can define what it means to be a
drug injector we can define what it
means to live in San Francisco so it's a
well posed problem it's not a problem
stating what we're trying to do but it's
hard for me to imagine a situation where
financially and ethically will be able
to make this sort of gold standard
measure so how is it that we can move
beyond just saying well these are all
different in practice what happens
usually so in this case all of these
were produced by one research group so
we don't fight within ourselves very
much but I've been to a lot of meetings
where people someone does it one way
someone does it the other way and then
they kind of argue and whoever can yell
the loudest that's the estimate that
ends up being used and that is really
not what we want like to have some way
that we can actually reliably make
progress and distinguish between
different people's claims so I think
there's sort of two main ways that we
could try to do that one way is
theoretically and one way is empirically
so theoretically i mean we could have
statements like if x y and z are true
then method 1 is better than method 2
i'm actually not very optimistic about
this which i probably should not say in
a room full of theorists I let me tell
you why in this particular setting it's
very difficult to make statements like
that because even to make a clear
statement like if x y and z are true you
often have to assume other things a B
and C which are definitely not true so
that statement is of limited value
another reason that statement is of
limited value is because
often hard to know if XY and z are true
because if in these populations are
hidden we really do not know that much
about them it's very hard to reliably
measure any of these things so I'm not
very optimistic about this theoretical
approach so I wanted to try to come up
with some empirical way that we can make
progress it would not require a lot of
untestable or unrealistic assumptions
and so that's what we've tried to do so
let me talk a little bit about the
setting in which we do this so we've
come up with a way to try to do this
with in something called the network
scallop method so now I'm going to tell
you a little bit about the network
scallop method and how it works and then
I'll tell you about how we can try to
reliably make progress within the
framework of this method so the original
insight behind this method was developed
by an anthropologist named Russ Bernard
who was in mexico city in 1985 during
the terrible earthquake that happened
there so at the time of the earthquake
there were widely different measures of
the number of people who had been killed
and it was particularly politically
contentious because the government had
been putting out lower estimates and
other people had been putting out higher
awesome and so no one really knew what
was going on and ross said well hmm
everyone that i talked to seems to know
someone who's died in the earthquake so
it can't be true that there's only a
very small number of fatalities so the
insight that there's somehow information
within the personal networks of the
survivors about the number of people who
have passed away and so then Ross and
some of his colleagues have worked for a
long time trying to turn that intuition
into a statistical method so here's how
it works so here's a population of 30
people let's say six of whom have red
hair we'd like to estimate how many
people have red hair so we can take a
sample of one of those people we can see
that this person is connected to ten
other people two of whom have red hair
so that our estimate for the size of the
target population that is the number of
people thread hair is just the
prevalence within the personal network
of the respondent times the total number
of people in the population which in
this case gives us an estimate of six
which is exactly right so this method is
awesome
so obviously you would not want to do
this with just one person so if you take
a larger sample this is the estimator
that you get and the rough intuition for
this is you can think of it as sort of a
generalized sample proportion so in a
normal sample proportion you take the
number of people who say yes divided by
the number of people that you talk to
hear you take the number of people that
are connected to the respondents who
have that trait so the number of drug
injectors connected to your respondents
/ the estimated number of people who are
connected to your respondents and then
again you take that proportion you
project it over the whole population so
that's the intuition for the meth you
that is absolutely right so that is one
of the many problems with this estimator
so one of the things we did which I
don't want to talk about exactly here is
we've come up with ways of trying to
estimate the average degree of people in
the target population which would allow
us to undo this problem okay so how does
this work in practice how does the data
collection actually happen so it
requires a random sample from the entire
population it does not require a sample
from the hard to reach group which is a
big advantage unless you want to
estimate some of these correction
factors in which case you do need a
sample from the hard to reach population
and that would be a separate talk so the
respondents are asked questions like how
many people do you know who are drug
injectors these are the pop target
populations and then they're asked about
a bunch of populations that where we
know the answer so how many women's you
know they've given birth in the last 12
months how many people do you know who
are middle school teachers how many
people do now named Michael these are
all groups where we know the sizes of
these groups from administrative records
so roughly what's happening is these
questions go are going into estimating
the respondents degree so that's the
denominator and
and this is the numerator and then one
question in terms of the
operationalization is also how do we
define what it means to know someone
else so here the way it's typically
defined as you know them and they know
you and you've been in contact with them
in the last two years so it's a
particularly weak notion of a tie I
guess everyone here is familiar with the
idea of weaker and stronger ties so this
struck us is kind of an interesting
thing because it's something that every
previous study has used basically this
definition and it's extremely weak
definition of a tie so we thought maybe
that's not actually not the optimal
definition of thai spec maybe we could
get better estimates if we tuned this
parameter some and so we asked ross like
how did you guys come up with this
definition and so we just thought it
seemed reasonable for the first time
it's like okay that makes sense and then
everyone else is pretty much kept doing
it and but in fact this is actually
something that we the researchers can
choose and tuned to try to get better
estimates so let me sketch out a cartoon
model of why I think this might not be
the best definition i should put
modeling quotes in this audience i guess
so you can imagine a ray of Pi strengths
from very strong to very weak and as the
tie definition gets weaker and weaker
you can sort of imagine we're collecting
more and more information from each
respondent so you would imagine that
your sampling error would go down but
you also might imagine that your non
sampling error would go up that is
people don't have perfect information
about their weaker ties so you might
imagine as the ties get weaker and
weaker the non sampling error would go
up and up and so then if you put these
together you get something that looks
like this where you think your error is
a function of the tie strength and then
when you see a picture like this you
naturally would like to know what that
point is so we set out to try to find
that so we did this in a survey
experiment in Rwanda so this is a study
funded by the UN and you
say ID to estimate the sizes of the
groups most at risk for HIV in Rwanda so
these are drug injectors female sex
workers clients and female sex workers
and men who have sex with men and we had
a nationally representative sample of
5,000 Rwanda ins face to face interview
this sample was selected using standard
probability methods so now what we did
is we had a survey experiment where half
of the people got one definition of what
it means to be connected to someone else
and half got a different so half of the
respondents got this basic definition
which is modeled after the definition
that I've been used a lot in the past
someone that you know by sight in by
name and that also knows you by sight in
by name so this is to produce
reciprocity people that you've had some
contact with in the past 12 months and
people of all ages who live in Rwanda so
then the other half of the respondents
got this meal definition which is also
people you know by sight and by name but
people who have shared a meal or a drink
with in the past 12 months and again
people of all ages live in Rwanda so
these two definite this stronger
definition is completely nested within
the weaker definition okay so and we
also so then the so before I say sort of
what happens I want to say that like we
really did not know what was going to
happen exactly so no one had done a
study like this in sub-saharan Africa
using the scallop method and also if you
think about it for a second these
questions are actually quite difficult
to answer so I'm going to just ask you
all how many women do have you shared a
meal or a drink with in the past 12
months that have given birth in the past
12 months just think about it for a
second okay so it's hard for you people
with PhDs who think about networks to
answer these questions and you know one
thought we even have is well the answers
that we're going to get are going to be
complete gibberish or people maybe
aren't even going to respond to the
actual text of the question like how do
we know this is even going to do
anything so one of the first things we
did when we got back to
data oh so let me tell you all so
quickly about the groups of known size
that we use because this is going to be
important so we have 12 different names
these are names that are relatively
common in Rwanda and we know the number
of people who have these names from the
national ID database and then these are
groups defined by occupation or
demographic status and these are known
through government records or through
other large scale surveys so here for
all of those groups the x-axis is the
mean number of reported connections to
people in this group using the basic
definition and here's the mean number of
ties reported using the meal definition
so what we see is in all cases for all
the groups under the meal definition
people give smaller answers so like they
were actually listening to the question
and they gave answers in ways that we
would expect that was like that was
pretty cool and you see that this is
kind of approximately consistent which
suggests the shrinking is pretty much
the same for each group so next what we
can do and this is sort of really what
allows us to actually try to make some
progress is that we can pretend we don't
know the size of a group and then try to
estimate it using all the information
from all the other groups so here on the
x-axis is the true size and this of
course only works for the group's where
we know the true size and then here is
the estimated size in this setting where
we pretend we don't know it and try to
use the other groups so obviously this
would work perfect if all of these lie
on the 45 degree line and to a first
approximation it's not the estimates are
not terrible which is nice and these are
the values for the basic definition of
these for the meal definition so this is
for example women who have given birth
in the last 12 months this is the the
true value is closed 2.25 when we try to
estimate it's about point O 2 so then
the question is if we wanted to decide
which definition seems to be working
better the basic definition or the meal
definition yep
yes so this is one thing that's been
observed in a number of these studies
which is that people this is not just in
Rwanda was also in data from the US and
data from Brazil people seem to give
higher answers seem to over report
knowing people in smaller groups and
under report knowing people in bigger
groups we don't know the exact origin of
this response pattern we think it might
be that people subtly change the
definition of what it means to be
connected to someone so if I say how
many people do you know named ulysses
you might like search deep in your
memory for someone who you went to high
school with named ulysses and you might
report that but if i said how many
people do you know named Michael you're
less likely to reach as far back in your
net but that's pure speculation we have
no idea but that pattern has been
observed in other data sets as well so
you might imagine you could try to
systematically correct for that but then
obviously so you could sort of just
empirically correct for that but you
like to sort of understand why it is
before you start doing some stuff to it
so then we said okay so which of these
seems to be working better so we want to
summarize basically how far off these
estimates are from the true values so
there are many ways to do that so we
could use root mean squared error mean
absolute error average relative error
under many different error metrics the
meal definition works better than the
standard definition so then here are the
estimates for the so here we've said
here's the question of okay how do we
decide this tie definition now in a lot
of other work in this area it would be
like well I think it should be this and
I think it should be this and I think
it's because and then it would just be
like never ending so like here we have a
clear pre specified criteria for
deciding and by several different error
metrics one works better than the other
so like you've actually potentially made
some progress this plot is telling us
that the red date on the previous slide
should look better to us than the blue
that's what it's telling us I mean
you're it's not a huge difference i'm
going to show you also in a second so
there's two parts of this
I think one is the actual result and
then two is the recipe which I'll talk
about a little bit at the end so here
are the four target populations here are
the estimates using the basic definition
in the middle definition so first you'll
see that basically they're quite similar
which is actually I think quite good I
was pleasantly surprised that we're able
to get quite different answers but yet
the amount that the numerator shrinks in
the amount of denominator shrinks we end
up with quite similar estimates in the
end also we could talk a little bit more
about the face validity of these
estimates estimates that they're almost
zero injecting drug users in Rwanda this
is very consistent with expectations of
people they're basically heroine is not
produced locally so it has to be
imported and so it either is flown in or
comes in overland through Tanzania which
is also very expensive there aren't a
huge number of people in Rwanda with
lots of disposable income so you just
aren't a lot of drug injectors there
this is very so some sense this was
something they thought there would be
close to zero and we estimate there was
close to zero so that's good men who
have sex with men this very complicated
and confusing it's very clear that there
are very few openly gay people in Rwanda
as far as how many people who identify
as heterosexual are actually have sex
with other men I don't know and I don't
think anyone really knows and then these
estimates are also roughly consistent
with their expectations although we
estimate similar numbers of sex workers
and clients of sex workers which is
something that they were surprised they
thought there would be many more clients
than actual sex workers but again you
could imagine situations where this how
this makes sense okay so then they saw
this is it great so what should we tell
the minister I think okay well we think
the meal definitions work better based
on these criteria so let's tell the
minister this they say but what about
the rest of the data we've this is 2500
interviews those are very expensive we
you know that took months of hard work
traveling around the country
he said that's right we should not
actually throw away this other half of
the data so then we do some kind of
blending so you can imagine that your SN
for the size of the target population
would be some kind of weighted average
between the two definitions and then
here we define the way to be basically
about the relative mean squared errors
and so in this case it's about
two-thirds so you can think of RS are
blended estimate a sort of two-thirds
meal one-third basic and that produces
these estimates here which are you know
in the middle okay so then this gives us
a sort of general recipe that we can use
so we take our sample we split it into
two arms wisely the two three you know
if you're nearing that sweet spot of
yours oh yeah so ideally we'd like to do
now we would like to do three this first
time we actually had a lot of trouble
convincing them even to do too because
so all of these surveys were done on
paper and the actual it was non-trivial
to actually implement the clean survey
experiment in a paper-based world so
given these results and also we don't
yet know exactly at the time we were
trying to convince them we have no real
examples of this doing something so it's
much harder so we settled for two so
we've done these two then we get
estimates from each arm then we blend
the estimates here so then each study
produces two things one is the blended
estimate that's what actually the
Minister wants that's what the minister
pays for and then as a second sort of
by-product we get a comparison between
these two so that allows us to say well
in this case the meal definition seems
to work slightly better than the basic
definition so then every study can
produce these two things one the thing
that the people who are funding the
study care about and then two is this
little extra bit and so at this point
there have been like 450 studies around
the world using respondent driven
sampling this is the other method that I
worked on and there have been very
little accumulation of knowledge from
all of those studies it's just kind of
there's a lot of estimates and then a
little
accumulation so here if we imagine doing
a hundred scale-up studies and if every
study has one of these experiments in it
then after you're done 100 of them will
actually learn a lot so then we can talk
a little bit about the trade-offs
involved in it so this is not completely
free so one great thing is it requires
no additional information from the
respondents it doesn't require you to
increase your sample size it doesn't
require you to ask additional questions
to the respondents because that stuff is
automatically collected with scallop
method it's slightly more difficult
logistically because you have to
operationalize this field experiment and
then it makes the analysis slightly more
complicated however dennis is working on
in our package which will make the
analysis much easier so we're hoping
that will basically decrease the added
cost of doing this such that this will
become a standard thing in every study
so to sort of wrap up the question that
I started with was how can we improve if
we don't know how we're doing and so in
this case we can see that we can have a
sort of general recipe which we can use
within the scallop method to try to
gradually accumulate evidence over time
to make sure we're getting better and
better and I hope you can figure out how
to do that with the other problems in
this area as well thank you yep
not necessarily yeah it's a huge problem
so it one thing someone asked me after
the earthquake in Haiti like could we go
do this in Haiti right now and it's like
that I think the amount that people want
these estimates is like related to how
difficult it is to make these estimates
in some sense so like we can't really go
into the Philippines now and take a
standard probability sample it's just
that that infrastructure a lot of that
infrastructure has been wrecked so we
could go and do something but like you
said if if the initial sample is somehow
non-representative so for somehow
missing people from certain regions and
you can imagine the kinds of estimates
that will get from this would not be
totally right now they're waving ways of
sort of modifying this and one of the
things that dennis is working on in his
dissertation is generalizing this sort
of much more to acute accommodate lots
of different methods where you have
people reporting about other people and
then that can introduce a variety of
problems like this problem here that
some people get reported about more
times than other people but so there may
be i don't think this exact thing will
work but i think the idea of asking
people about the people that they know
is is a possibility yeah so I mean um
I'm sure you didn't intend us but you
sort of implicitly suggested you know
this idea that you have a single
parameter when you can tune to kind of
make neighborhoods bigger or smaller the
graph definition more or less dense but
of course I mean just things like have
you had a meal with somebody versus this
other definition this is complete apples
and oranges right if it could be that if
Emile you said a drink you get
completely different types of responses
and recall from people right so what
about doing what you're suggesting but
kind of standardizing some definition
which really does have a tunable
parameter I mean it could be something
like you know
the number of years you ask them to
think you know it have a meal and just
make it a little bit more systematic so
here you could imagine so basically we
decided to to basically what it means
have contact you're saying you could
also tune what time period was used that
would be much more systematic well I'm
not preferring one over the other I'm
just not referring sort of definitely
incomparable definitions of recall i
would say these are not incomparable in
the sense that they're nested within
each other yeah so that was the one that
was our first criteria yes I guess the
question is could you does it make sense
empirically to think about not just sort
of two points on that yeah to continue
right and actually suggesting that
people are going to use this methodology
a hundred times going forward that they
stick within that you know spectrum no I
totally agree so like the thing that we
it's not even clear that there is this
just one dimension here yeah so this is
how we chose to operationalize this idea
this time I think it would be great if
we can have a more general definition
that would allow for I see so what
you're saying is if we do a hundred
studies we'd rather them all be
connected within some overarching
framework rather than be 100 sort of
bits and pieces that's definitely true I
will say one thing about the challenge
of this and the challenge of this method
overall is that it requires you to use
concepts that are meaningful in that
society so initially when we went there
we said okay we're going to talk about
sharing meals contact and sharing meals
and our collaborators said no actually
very few people in Rwanda go out to eat
together have people over to eat which
is not very common there but sharing
drinks is much more common so we added
that this drink thing is totally an
add-on and so you can really only use
sort of kind of social constructions
that exist within that society this is
the problem
people yes absolutely ok so we yeah man
and so we have a half an hour for a
discussion I guess the plan is to turn
the cameras off and I guess they're
going to bring some chairs up sat right
Carolyn